[Musique]
il y a plus qu'une dizaine d'années un
collègue me raconte qu'il existe des
microbes qui produit l'électricité est
enjimmi est devenu biotechnologique ça
m'intriguait et je me demandais comment
ça fonctionne et la bioélectricité est
pas quelque chose qu'on nous parviennent
quotidiennement mais on sait il ya des
poissons électrique situation électrique
et gestes d'autrefois sont pas des
électrochocs pour les avaler pour se
nourrir
l'objectif et outils sont bien claires
mais si on parle maintenant des microbes
qui produit l'électricité
c'est beaucoup moins claire et
d'ailleurs on peut pas les observer à
l'onu on a besoin d'un microscope ou
mieux comprendre pourquoi ils produisent
une électricité
il faut retourner au début de cette
planète cette planète étaient couverts
par des volcans et dans l'atmosphère il
n'y avait pas d'oxygène qui fait que la
zot mettant co2 hydrogène et on pense
que ces premiers micro ont eu envie pas
facile
donc probablement ils ont se greffer à
la surface des pierres volcaniques qui
contenaient des métaux oxydé et ils ont
envoyé des électrons sur ces rochers
pour s installer une sorte de
respiration
les électrons qui passent là ce sont des
plus petites unités dont l'univers qui
transporte l'électricité par exemple vos
chaises là il y à pleins vraiment plein
d'électro mais ça fait rien vous avez
pas d électrochoc comme ça mais dont
votre corps il y à pleins d'électrons 10
millions qui assure que vous pouvez
respirer comme ces microbes
ces microbes qui sont électriques
on a découvert il y a à peu près 40 ans
le premier c'était le cheval et la dont
la con nayda près de new york
il y un deuxième qui s'appelle bo back
tail qui fait la même chose
les deux sont relativement bien décrit
mais il ya d'autres beaucoup d'autres en
fait on les découvertes ont aussi dans
la vraie toile et sont pas des cris on
n'a pas le temps pour les décrire il est
tellement beaucoup de choses à faire
dans ce domaine
on travaille avec ce qu'on a et on
essaie de produire une électricité donc
la production d'électricité maintenant
avec tmx rock
je vais vous expliquer cela avec des
microbes là une rouge une bleue la
louche et négatifs bleus est positif
ici sur cette côte et on a ces microbes
ces microbes qui mangent la nourriture
qui est dans liquide autour
il digère il ya des électrons qui sont
libérés il passe par mon corps
ils arrivent ici à la positif à la
cocotte et là il ya l'oxygène de l'air
donc je suis sous tension je sais pas si
on peut le
c'est une électricité douce donc je vais
pas mourir avant la fin de ce
présentation maintenant un peu plus
scientifique
là il ya une animation on a su la gauche
des électrons jaune qui sont négatifs et
rouge
ce sont des pelotons ils sont positifs
mais non ses électeurs ils sont
enchantés loin des microbes sur cet
électorat est un électeur qui est jeté
en dehors qui est tout à coup tout seul
on dit c'est malheureux ça cherche tout
de suite un partenaire est probablement
ça va le trouver dont la catho tu là il
ya probablement deuxième électeurs
également négatif est aussi en couple
les deux restent négatifs on peut dire
faire mais il faut pas désespérer
maintenant il est encore l'être autant
qu'ils sont toujours positifs ils ont
positif
il peut être tout seul ou en couple ou à
plusieurs ça fait rien donc
donc ça passe également vers la droite
et une fois l'électron est peloton sont
passées on concentre en effet électrique
là le petit vous tourner comme un moulin
qui produit la farine et le fin de ce
processus et la production de l'eau
l'eau qu'on pouvait boire si vous voulez
donc cette pile et hautement durable
c'est le dell seuls déchets qui s'y est
produit à l'eau mais non on voit aux
laboratoires et aux laboratoires
on examine si tout c'est vrai ce que je
vous raconte
et on utilise ces petits tracteurs des
motos futur d'électricité
et on constate que ça ne dit pas
beaucoup d'électricité un peu on peut
changer les paramètres qui ont vent
tient plus naturellement et c'est ce
qu'on fait chez nous mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'électricité alors vous pouvez
vous imaginer à 0 5 volts et on a
cherché d'électronique quelques années
qui transforme cette électricité dans
une électricité qui vous permettrait de
l'enquêté de télé à la maison
le télé consomme 220 volts passer aux 5
donc on aurait besoin 440 réacteurs en
ligne pour avoir cette puissance a le
bon peuple faciliter cette tâche avec
une électronique
mais il ya plusieurs groupes de
recherche qui essayent effectivement
réalisé ça mais je suis un professeur a
une haute école spécialisée
mon mandat et la recherche appliquée
donc appliqué sa vie dit il
ça devait être utile bientôt et on était
à un moment où on a réfléchi si on est
sur le bon projet et aussi notre mi
corps était pas trop content avec la
situation parce qu'on est arrivé pas
valoriser ces honneurs fort et on a
réfléchi bien là dessus on a trouvé une
idée géniale on te vole pas on utilise
ce qu'on a
pour résoudre le plus grand problème du
monde dont on n'en parle pas c'est la
crise des phosphates est effectivement
avec cette micro hop on arrive avec
notre pile à combustible nucléaire de
produire un engrais qui est plus pur que
la législation demande un jour des
résultats pour la scientifique s'est pas
le quotidien mais pour une fois c'est
bien
je vais maintenant vous expliquer
qu'est-ce qui est ce problème et comment
elle a résolu le problème est que
l'agriculture a besoin d engrais sans
engrais il n'y a pas de création des
plantes au une croissance qui n est pas
très bien derrière ces plantes ils ont
reçu un engrais de phosphates et devons
pas la différence dont la croissance est
énorme et on voit que l'agriculture a
besoin vraiment des ongrais hautement se
marche pas on n'a pas assez de
nourriture
maintenant tout vient cette phosphate 7
phosphate vient des mines au maroc dont
les états unis et en chine
on le transforme dans un anglais mais
sarah dans l'agriculture aujourd'hui des
aliments se passe chez nous on se
nourrit et sur ce trajet pas tout on
perd le phosphate dont l'environnement
finalement c'est perdu dans
l'environnement complètement diluée on
peut pas le récupérer comme ça et il
faut savoir que cette phosphate dans ces
mines ont 50 à 80 ans on a rien dans
cette nuit après il faut le remplacer
mais c'est pas tout c'est encore plus
grave
en 2030 cp dit qu'il y à un pic au
phosphate
le pico phosphate seraient ensemble au
pico foil pétrole alors à partir de ce
moment là il n'y a plus assez de
phosphate sur le marché et s'il n'y a
pas assez mal il faut soit sur le marché
on peut plus produire la nourriture
essayez pas cette nourriture bien plan
chances que la population mondiale va
des cloîtres pour combattre ça on pense
que les stations d'épuration peut aider
les stations d'épuration il reçoit les
eaux usées des cuisines des toilettes
des entreprises et on le traite avec des
microbes
et on obtient des boues d'épuration
ces boues d'épuration contient également
le phosphate
mais ces boues sont polis et avec des
métaux toxiques et ont produit
énormément que des quantités des boues à
de ces petites collines là en réalité ce
sont des énormes quantités
les villes ne seul sport comme il faut
se déplacer de cela et on le brûle et
après on le jette
on peut pas l'utiliser parce que c'est
pollué et en fait c'est la source la
plus riche en phosphates qui va rester
un jour donc il faut essayer de trouver
une solution et notre solution est de
mettre maintenant des électrons taux des
bassins d'épuration des stations vertes
figuration outre cette électricité cette
publicité pour église et le phosphate
qui est dans les boues d'épuration notre
réacteur ici au milieu c'est un acte un
des plusieurs qu'on a construit ce petit
réacteur là au milieu une partie blanche
dans cette partie blanche
on met les boues qui sont à gauche dont
sept centres dont le réacteur et sur les
côtés transparents là il ya l'eau usée
et là on produit l'électricité comme est
au centre de ces réacteurs
ce travail dedans c'est des réactions
électrochimiques il ya plusieurs je vais
pas vous ennuyer avec les détails là
mais ce qu'on obtient et un surnageant
qui contient le phosphate qu'on a libéré
se noue surnageant ont des comptes comme
vieux vin et dont ces liquides
on rajoute un peu de magnésium
d'ammonium est un engrais précipite et
si on enlève cette clé si pete et on
constate que c'est en gras est plus pur
que la législation demande
on pense que cette concept est utile
parce qu on a l'énergie dans l'eau qu'on
peut utiliser
on a le phosphate dans l'eau qu'on peut
utiliser avec nos micros
transfert cette énergie en électricité
le même temps on produit un onglet le
même temps ambrosi l'eau pure on est en
train de grandir ses deux réacteurs
on va vers les 5 solide pour l'instant
est appelée vers un démonstrateur et on
espère qu on peut l'appliquer partout
merci
[Applaudissements]